going into this Emmys excitement it's
bittersweet because it's the last one
for veep
all of the above I mean it's awfully
nice to be invited back to the party
again but you know and and it also I'm
gonna admit and we're sort of I can feel
it we're all kind of hanging on it
because it's an opportunity for us to
get together again and so we're having a
few parties in advance of the Emmys and
because we want to get together you know
I mean it's a very close-knit group of
people so Tony was almost in tears
talking about it he said he's throwing
in dinner two weeks before and I
suggested maybe that's the time we
planned the Emmys hijinx
for veep like winning or losing are we
gonna get on stage is there gonna be
like a high jinks I don't know I haven't
with I haven't gone there yet in my mind
this is a historic all jokes aside this
is a historic nomination for you if you
win you will be the most winningest
performer that has ever existed at the
Emmys you I mean you don't think about
it
well it's it's a big deal it is a big
deal you know but I mean look I've
already won because making and I know it
sounds like corny but it's really true
making veep has been is a win it has
been a huge win in my life and and the
trophies are fabulous don't get me wrong
it's wonderful to win those but the real
win is in the work and we've worked our
asses off on this show and so and we've
had a grand time doing it so but anyway
I'm just happy to be invited back to
this party
when you did the finale for Seinfeld
there was mixed reviews about the ending
for veep did you feel the pressure of
like so many people shows so beloved you
had to get it right and then now that
it's out there how's the reaction been
well I did feel the pressure not so much
because of Seinfeld but just because I
put it on myself
I've been fiercely protective of the
quality of this show for eight years
like fiercely okay and so I did not want
to screw this up from a creative point
of view and the reaction has been very
enthusiastic I think people really like
the the finale it was good for I think
it stood on its own as if as a episode
of the show and I also think if you were
a big veep fan there were so many
callbacks and Easter eggs within it
including the Tom Hanks joke which which
harken back to the pilot as did a few
other jokes back to the very pilot of
them and I think what happened is that
I've been asking everyone kind of
tongue-in-cheek I could we do a spin-off
could we do a reboot but to me with a
finale you guys kind of like check mark
like it's I don't know that there's any
more veep to be done like it really was
kind of a perfect bow good I'm glad you
that yes I'm very proud of it I really
am I think we we worked long and hard
and went through many iterations of what
it was going to be really many and so I
think we landed in the right spot and
looking back going into this Emmys and
going to this sort of final hurrah for
veep this show has meant so much to you
as a character and then the way your
life has changed things you've overcome
during that time what does it meant to
you to have the support of these people
and just this show bead like the
grounding force during that time well I
have to say that that's their sort of a
long answer here but I would say that I
had a lot of personal challenges
losses of dear ones in my family and my
own battle with cancer
and had I not have had this really close
intimate relationship with all of these
people with whom we linked we linked
arms and we we we tried to do the most
joyful funny thing possible as a team it
was like being on a sports team except
it was you know for entertainment
purposes and that was the most booing
thing to constantly be coming back to
and it really helped me it gave me
something to laser focus on during my
illness and I needed to laser focus
beyond my illness so yeah it was a
lifesaver
[Music]